der titel heißt blockseminar und
wirklich seminar warum heißt das so sie
fragen sich was soll das schreibt man
blockseminar nicht mit ck eigentlich
nein also man kann eben versuchen
traditionelle und moderne digitale
medien oder leer form zu vereinen und
ich sage ihnen jetzt ganz kurz was ich
vorhabe jetzt in den folgen der
folgenden stunde als ich will erst mal
ganz kurz was sagen zum thema digitale
lehre digitale transformation kann dass
die traditionellen seminar form ersetzen
in der skeptisch ich sagte ja gleich ein
bisschen was dazu zum rahmen sozusagen
dieser ganzen projekte dann werde ich
ganz kurz darauf eingehen welche
möglichkeiten des einsatzes von
digitalen medien sich bieten also was
für digitale medien es überhaupt gibt
und wofür die geeignet sind können sie
sich auch schon überlegen ob es für ihn
von ihrem fach besonders gute medien
eventuell gebe wir reden da dann noch
mal drüber dann auch ganz wichtig die
studien technische integration digitaler
medien es genügt nicht medien zu haben
die sich vielleicht gut eignen würden
man muss auch immer rücksprache halten
wie der studiengangs koordination gerade
dann wenn es um referate oder um seminar
leistung geht die angerechnet werden
müssen da empfiehlt es sich frühzeitig
schon kontakt aufzunehmen nicht nach
dass man nachher so ein ganz tolles
projekt hat man sagen die studiengangs
koordination toren das passt jetzt aber
mit ihren studiengang ein wir können da
keine kredite vergeben oder das ist
rechtlich bedenklich das geht gar nicht
es sollte man natürlich davor abklären
dann gehe ich auf dieses konzept des
blogs seminar ist ein beschreibt es ein
bisschen auch auf das konzept wirklich
seminar was es damit auf sich hat und
ich gehe ganz kurz da noch einen
ausblick auf digitale angebote der lmu
also auf die frage wie sie konkret für
ihr projekt infrastruktur hier nutzen
können also welche angebote hier nicht
nur vom center-management auch von den
software entwicklern von den von der
gruppe geisteswissenschaft wie sie da
eine infrastruktur bekommen die ihnen
erlaubt möglichst schnell solche
projekte umzusetzen die ich da sehr
einsam entwickelt hatte weil ich auch
nicht wusste was es alles gibt man kommt
erst im lauf der zeit drauf und selbst
noch ein bisschen rum experimentieren
wollte also viele der arbeitsschritte
die ich mir gemacht hatte
sind völlig überflüssig die werden
abgenommen wenn sie die richtigen
kontakte hierzu universität haben und
ich will da noch ein kontakt am ende
nennen und ein paar angebote zum ersten
punkt ja sie haben alle auch das hemd
auch glaube ich von mir vor sich also
ich bin der meinung dass die digitale
medien medien digitale lehrformen nicht
das traditionelle seminar ersetzen
können vielleicht sogar auch nicht
ersetzen sollen warum erst mal zur
grundbedingung wir haben jetzt durch
diese pa studiengänge eigentlich keine
präsenzpflicht mehr also immer wieder
wenn es dann in seminaren heißt also ich
hätte gerne dass sie da sind regelmäßig
dann wird getuschelt das geht gar nicht
wenn ich dagegen klage dann komme ich
durch also mit der anwesenheitspflicht
ist eine sache man kann die studierenden
eigentlich gar nicht richtig
verpflichten regelmäßig zu kommen
natürlich ist es schön wenn sie kommen
das ist ganz klar
aber es gibt auch manchmal gründe frage
ist ob es gute oder schlechte gründe
sind gründe die dazu führen dass
studierende nicht regelmäßig teilnehmen
können oder wollen
ich führe ein paar nachher an häufiger
grund ist dass studierende nebenher noch
irgendwie arbeiten müssen oder dass sie
berufstätig sind oder dass sie eben auch
familie schon haben es gibt viele gründe
die dazu führen dass man vielleicht
nicht regelmäßig präsent sein kann und
ich glaube das digitale medien gerade da
einsetzbar sind wo man studierende
unterstützt wenn sie nicht regelmäßig
anwesend sein können dass nicht der
einzige grund aber das kommt den sehr
entgegen also man hat schon mal diese
rahmenbedingung dass man diese nicht
präsenz die sie nicht physische präsenz
der studierenden kompensieren kann indem
man ihnen digitale angebote begleitend
transformieren zur verfügung stellen
die grundbedingung dann wir haben durch
digitale medien räumliche und zeitliche
flexibilität wenn sie jetzt schaffen
sich ein digitales seminar einzurichten
ein blockseminar in wickie seminar eine
app quiz im internet dann sind sie
räumlich völlig unabhängig ihre
studierenden können jederzeit darauf
zugreifen in der u-bahn in der pause vom
seminar wenn sie noch immer unterwegs
sind also sind völlig unabhängig genauso
zeit
sie müssen das ganze nicht nur auf diese
zwei oder vier stunden in der woche
konzentrieren das kann ausgelagert
werden jeder teilnehmer kann selbst
bestimmen wann er sich vorbereitet wenn
er sich nach bereitet also das ist eine
große flexibilität gegeben ist und die
eben auch durch die neuen pa
studiengänge unterstützt wird das hatte
ich schon gesagt das ist ein enormer
vorteil für studierende mit kindern
berufstätige aber auch kurzzeitig
erkrankte das sollte man auch nicht
vergessen und hat alles digital parat
und das ist mir aber auch noch ganz
wichtiger nächster punkt man kann
seminarinhalte dokumentieren man kann
sie archivieren und kann sie vernetzen
man kann also wikis wiki systeme stellen
nicht zeigt nach noch wie das geht man
kann auf ein seminar verweisen was man
vor zwei jahren gegeben hat das ganz
ähnlich war
man kann es damit verlinken mit dem
aktuellen seminar und es ist so die
seminar diskussion gerade im fall der
philosophie das merke ich immer die
verpufft so schnell
nachdem die zwei stunden rum sind dann
frage ich mich häufig selbst als
studierender auch aber auch als dozent
was ist jetzt eigentlich rübergekommen
wir haben da schon diskutiert
interessante fragen aber die sind alle
weg und so eine digitale struktur
erlaubt ist über verschiedene
möglichkeiten zum beispiel durch
referate die man nachbereiten lässt die
man dann ins internet stellen oder durch
audioaufzeichnung oder durch
videoaufzeichnungen diese inhalte zu
fixieren sie nicht nur zu fixieren sie
zu archivieren sie zu dokumentieren und
im besten fall auch zu vernetzen das
kann dadurch geschehen dass man wenn man
ein referat hat ein stundenprotokoll ein
referat zentrale begriffe in ein wiki
system einspeist und dann diesen text
hypertext verlinkt zentrale begriffe wie
bei wikipedia sie kennen das alles die
erscheinen als blau unterlegt und man
kann von begriff zur begriff springen es
gibt also eine vernetzung nicht nur eine
dokumentation ist eine vernetzung das
scheint mir auch ganz wichtig zu sein
dann was auch ein vorteil der digitalen
medien ist ist der unmittelbare zugriff
ich habe die erfahrung gemacht dass pro
zusätzlichen klick den der zugang
erfordert zu den inhalten man praktisch
mit der hälfte
prozent hälfte der anzahl der
studierenden weniger rechnen muss also
je mehr klicks ich habe umso weniger
potenzielle nutzer habe ich jeder klick
der zusätzlich erforderlich ist um zu
einem inhalt zu gelangen
halbiert mir die zahl der potenziellen
nutzer also ist es eine grobe geschätzt
ich habe keine absoluten statistiken
aber das so meinen erfahrungswert also
ganz wichtig ist es sage ich vorneweg
wenn sie digitale inhalte schaffen
digitale seminar sich erstellen
versuchen sie das so benutzerfreundlich
zu mal machen wie es nur irgendwie
möglichst wenige klicks und das würden
wir auch zum modeln modeln finde ich
eine ganz tolle idee aber modell ist für
meinen geschmack noch zu vermittelt ich
muss zu viele anmelde schritte
durchführen um zu den eigentlichen
inhalten zu kommen hinzu kommt dass
manchen lehrangeboten bei moodle der
inhalt geschützt ist den haben also nur
angemeldete nutzer bei diesem
blockseminaren die ich jetzt habe und
den folgenden zeigen werde ist es so
dass prinzipiell jeder interessent
zugreifen kann man kann dann natürlich
gewisse inhalte wie texte die copyright
geschützt sind oder sonstige interner
seminaristen teilnehmerlisten e mail
listen passwortgeschützt darauf stellen
dann schließt es nicht aus aber ich bin
der meinung man sollte wenn man diesen
digitalen weg geht dem trend des
internets folgen und die heißt nun
öffentliche zugänglichkeit und
unmittelbarkeit ich glaube diese zwei
prinzipien sind ganz wichtig für die
digitale lehrerin
das sind jetzt also die
rahmenbedingungen grundsätzlich und wie
gesagt meine these ist die digitalen
medien können die traditionelle seminar
vom nicht ersetzen sollen sie glaube ich
auch gar nicht weil das traditionelle
seminar hat so viele stärken das hat
diese unmittelbarkeit des austauschs von
angesicht zu angesicht
die physische präsenz die man nicht
unterschätzen darf aber das digitale
seminar die digitalen medien können
diese keimzelle der gedanken im seminar
an der universität in diesen
rahmenbedingungen fortführen
transformieren im besten fall das wäre
es um ein plädoyer also nicht ersatz
sondern erweiterung oder im besten fall
kommt eine transformation
wie das genau auszusehen hat oder
aussehen kann werden wir gleich zehn
jetzt vorneweg
habe ich immer einen kurzen einblick in
dieses spektrum diesen bunten strauß an
digitalen medien der sich uns heutzutage
gerade auch jetzt bietet war vor zehn
jahren sei es doch noch anders aus es
gab diese ganzen medien auch aber sie
waren lange nicht so kostengünstig so
unmittelbar zu erreichen und so schnell
vor allem von der geschwindigkeit her
was gibt es also zum einen kann man
gewisse erstellen mit automatische
auswertung
das kann man online oder offline machen
sie können also diesen quiz mit einem
link auf ihrer homepage vernetzen sodass
die teilnehmer über ihre homepage direkt
drauf klicken und dann lädt das quiz im
browser das können sie machen sie können
aber genauso gut das quiz als pdf datei
als pdf dokument oder als ex ausführbare
datei als exe-datei ihren teilnehmern
schicken das können sie selbst
entscheiden
der vorteil wenn sie das nur ins
internet stellen ist der dass die
teilnehmer eben das ganze dann nicht
weitergeben können sie jetzt mal und
also dass jeder der auf dieses quiz geht
es von neuem 8 sie haben sollen
die quiz resultate bei sich sie gehen
wir nicht aus der hand nehmen
sie können das aber auch als pdf machen
und verschicken ich zeige ihnen nachher
wie das geht und ein programm das sich
dafür sehr gut geeignet ist dieses adobe
captivate das ist ein sehr komplexes
programm auch nicht gerade teuer aber
man kann sich durchaus leisten und mit
dem kann und unglaublich tolle sachen
machen zb solche quizze mit automatische
auswertung also ihre studierenden
bekommen ein unmittelbares feedback
nachdem sie das quiz gelöst haben
entweder auf ihrem pc auf ihrem pr pdf
datei oder auch auf ihrer app also man
kann diese krise auch in die app
einbauen ich zeige ihm dass nachher wie
das aussieht also gewisse finde ich ganz
gut zur nachbereitung man kann sich
jetzt natürlich fragen häufig sind das
malte preuß quiz sind sie geeignet für
philosophie also mein chef würde mir
widersprechende würde sagen manche
features kann für die sophie nicht
abbilden ich glaube schon wenn man die
fragen geschickt wählt wenn man ganz
kleine feinheiten verändert dass man
ganz genau hinschauen muss dann kann man
auch mit multiple choice fragen
philosophisch inhalte vermitteln und bei
anderen fächern geht es sicherlich noch
besser dann blogs das ist vielleicht das
wichtigste da werde ich auch besonders
darauf eingehen blogs also ein eine
homepage die seminar beiträge ganz
aktuell zeitnah veröffentlicht in der
regel jedem interessenten und blogs kann
man sehr gut verwenden um darauf die
seminar diskussion abzubilden
um neue texte neue zusammenfassung von
sitzung zu sitzung wöchentlich online zu
stellen und nicht nur man selbst als
seminarleiter sind auch iris
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer können
das dann machen wenn man ihn
benutzerrollen zuweist es geht alles
sie können dann ihre protokolle ihre
referate ihre ich weiß nicht was in
medizin ihre bögen bei experimenten oder
in den naturwissenschaften können die
dann da online stellen natürlich bevor
es nach dem sie sich das auch angeschaut
haben sie können sich diese beiträge
vorlegen lassen dann sind sie in einem
privaten raum sie gehen dann nochmal
drüber geben dann das im primar
sozusagen oder sagen dem studierenden da
ist noch was nicht in ordnung bitte
bearbeiten sie das noch einmal reichen
sie es erneut ein und dann schauen sie
sich das an und geben das dann
gegebenenfalls frei und dann ist dieser
beitrag öffentlich sichtbar sie könnte
natürlich auch nur geschützt zugänglich
machen das ist auch möglich
das tolle an seinem blog ist dass sie im
laufe eines semesters sich ein riesen
archiv aufbauen
ja sie können innerhalb der beiträge
verlinken sie können auch manche
beiträge zitierfähig machen also man
kann dann auch sich immer wieder darauf
beziehen versionen werden archiviert das
ist also wissenschaftlich fundiert dann
das ist nicht irgendwie eine quelle die
das rumpf wird im internet sondern sie
als patient haben das durch gesehen sie
haben das im primat uhr gegeben und dann
kann man das unter umständen auch
zitieren an die wissenschaft kommt er
nicht zu kurz bei so einer sache also
blogs halte ich für eine ganz tolle
möglichkeit nicht zeigen nachher wie das
geht und vor allem mit wordpress also
wird alles haben sie sicherlich schon
mal gehört wordpress ist so ein system
mit dem sie kostenlos sehe einfach
unmittelbar wieder thema unmittelbarkeit
mit wenigen klicks auf ein beitrag
kommen aber auch mit wenigen klicks ein
beitrag erstellen können ich komme nach
noch ein bisschen näher auf wordpress zu
sprechen
dann über textuelle wikis als sie können
dann wenn sie einen blog haben und
beiträge von studierenden auf diesem
blog haben wie zb stunden protokolle
oder zusammenfassungen oder sogar
hausarbeiten ich habe es so gemacht dass
meine studierenden auch ihre
hausarbeiten dann darauf gestellt haben
wenn sie können sie dann verlinken sie
definieren bestimmte wiki einträge
zentrale begriffe und die werden dann
eben im jeweiligen beitrag wie auf
wikipedia blau unterlegt hypertext
verlinkt und so können sie von begriff
zu begriff springen und sie lernen dass
dann lernen dann bezüge herzustellen
nicht nur auf eine sache sich zu
konzentrieren so einen überblick zu
behalten das ist in der philosophie auch
ganz wichtig dass man sieht wie hängen
ganz wichtige begriffe miteinander
zusammen das kann aber auch für alle
anderen wissenschaften
zentral seien und sie haben dann
wirklich am ende sein kleines lexikon
sie haben sie im seminar lexikon
erstellt nachdem sie auch zitieren
können also meine seminarteilnehmer
haben dann auch aus diesem wiki system
selbst zitiert also mit datum des
letzten zugriffs usw also das geht dann
auch wenn die qualität stimmt dann
können sie diskussionsforen ein baum wo
ihre studierenden oder sie selbst
gewisse topix gewisse themenbereich
erstellen können gewisse diskussions
fragen unter den eine diskussion
stattfinden kann
das ist alles möglich und zwar durch
plugins als wenn sie wordpress einmal
haben dann gibt es verschiedene
zusatzprogramme plugins die sich in den
allermeisten fällen kostenlos der auf
ins system laden können oder laden
lassen können mit denen der neue
funktion freigeschaltet werden wie zum
beispiel diskussionsforum wie zum
beispiel wiki system das sind alles
zusatzprogramme die sie ganz flexibel
ergänzen können zumeist kostenlos dann
das ist so ein bisschen meinen fable sie
können apps erstellen das hat sich
extrem erleichtert also vor zehn jahren
war das noch nicht denkbar dass sie ihre
eigenen apps erstellen das ist aber
mittlerweile kein problem mehr
wenn sie einmal ein wordpress blog haben
diese wordpress struktur dann können sie
auf dieser basis verschiedene typen von
apps erstellen das einfachste ist html5
html5
ist jetzt ein standard der so gut ist
dass er nahezu alle funktionen
beinhaltet die früher nur über adobe
flash vielleicht haben sie schon mal
gehört flash adobe flash dieses programm
also animierte grafiken interaktive
dinge die konnten sie früher noch mit
flash machen jetzt können sie das mit
html5 machen
und der vorteil ist html5 ist nicht so
wären anfällig wie flash es ist viel
stabiler öffentlicher da hat sich
einiges getan
sie können aber auch sogenannte native
apps erstellen native apps sind apps die
dann extra programmiert werden das
kostet ein bisschen was ich habe da
einige apps erstellt ich zeigen die noch
einmal dass ein bisschen kosten müssten
sie selbst ein bisschen was zahlen die
frage ist ob sich das lohnt aber sie
können es auch ganz extrem professionell
machen über einen dritten anbieter dann
haben ihre teilnehmer eine app ihres
seminars auf dem smartphone sie können
den push notification schicken sie
können sie informieren auf dem laufenden
halten
ich mache das noch einmal sie dürfen
sich nachher ich kann sie schon vor
waren sie dürfen schon mal so langsam
ihre smartphones zücken weil sie sich
dann auch wenn sie wollen natürlich eine
meiner neuesten apps herunterladen
können dann verschicke ich hier mal live
eine push notification und schauen ob
das klappt das ist ein experiment an
also sowas können sie auch machen und im
html5 apps sind eben kostenlos deswegen
führe ich das an also hybrid apps sind
apps die teilweise nativ sind die also
teilweise sehr einheitlich generiert
sind und extrem professionell aussehen
html5 apps sind letztendlich so art
verknüpfungen die sie zu dieser seite
her stellen die aber zentral hinter
einem icon dann auf ihrem bildschirm
hinterlegt sind so dass sie mit einem
klick darauf kommen dass sie das thema
unmittelbarkeit sie müssen möglichst
wenig klicks auf den inhalt kommen und
bei apps haben sie ein riesenvorteil mit
einem klick mit einem tipp sind sie
sofort im menü sie haben ein menü sie
sehen dann an der seite bestimmte
kategorien nach denen sie ihre beiträge
ordnen können sie können auch auf die
des wiki system mit dann zwei klicks
zugreifen also apps haben eben diesen
vorteil dass sie extrem unmittelbar zu
bedienen sind
das möchte ich nur meinen aussicht
stellen dass es das auch gibt
und ich zuletzt videoaufzeichnungen und
themen sendung zb über eigene youtube
kanäle also youtube ist mittlerweile so
schnell und so verbreitet sie können das
wissen sie sicherlich sie können youtube
videos mit mit links ohne probleme in
anderen kontext einbetten sie sehen
sofort die vorschau sie können youtube
videos bewerten sie können youtube
videos kommentieren
wir haben hier jetzt an der lmu mit
apple viel gemacht mit itunes
ich finde youtube noch ein bisschen
besser intuitiv ist jetzt meine these
kann man mir auch wieder streiten
widersprechen ich halte youtube für
geeigneter weil es sich viel einfacher
verlinken lässt und viel öffentlicher
zugänglich ist
ich habe am eigenen youtube-kanal ich
zeig dir nachher auch mal was man damit
machen kann
genau jetzt noch ganz kurz zu den
studien technischen
integrationsproblemen ich hatte es
damals so gemacht ich hatte viele ideen
und dachte ach das auch toll ich mach
das und das und das und das und dann
sagt er mit der studiengangs berater ja
aber das geht nicht das ist rechtlich
nicht möglich wie stellen sie sich das
vor
und dann kam ich ein bisschen ins
schwitzen und musste etwas zurückrudern
also ich musste dann mit ihm das
absprechen ich muss das abstimmen und er
hat mir dann gesagt ist okay sie müssen
das aber offiziell dann auf dieser
webseite im lsf system angeben wie die
anforderung sind sie müssen sich was die
zeichenzahl angelangt genau nach den
vorgaben richten also ihre studierenden
geben dann keinen kurzfassung mehr ab
keine kurze haus arbeitet ein essay
sondern sie dürfen das dann online
stellen aber es müssen sie alles im
internet im lsf system angeben habe ich
dann gemacht und es war auch kein
problem wenn sie solche digitalen
beiträge sich erstellen lassen wollen
von ihren studierenden sei es jetzt
essays science protokolle science house
arbeiten seien es aber auch nur
diskussions kommentare in foren oder
unter anderen protokollen also wenn
jetzt ein teilnehmer ein protokoll
online stellt oder sie ist online
gestellt
haben dann können sie den anderen
teilnehmenden die möglichkeit einräumen
diese beiträge zu kommentieren
sie können darunter was schreiben und da
empfiehlt es sich vorab schon klare
regeln zu definieren wie dann die
digitale mitarbeit auszusehen hat zum
beispiel wie zu kommentieren ist gibt es
diese regel des feedbacks die sandwich
methode wie auch immer kann man alles
vor erklären also man soll immer
konstruktiv sein das habe ich gesagt
also die dürfen natürlich sehr gerne
fehler aufzeigen oder unklare dinge den
beitrag benennen
machen sie das konstruktiv also sagen
sie diese sache ist mir noch nicht klar
ich sehe das anders ich würde anregend
dass man das so macht und dann kann der
teilnehmende diese ganzen kommentare zu
seinen protokollen aufnehmen und bei mir
war es so am ende in seine hausarbeit
mit einnehmen sie konnten dann auf eine
ganze semester lang andauernde
diskussion zurückgreifen
ich habe verpflichtend gefordert dass
jeder teilnehmer drei konstruktive
kommentare während des semesters
hinterlassen muss also das empfiehlt
sich das etwas zwingend zu machen da
auch natürlich wieder abstimmung mit der
studiengang koordination ist es
rechtlich möglich ets punktemäßig sich
da einfach abzusichern und dann kann man
das durchaus einfordern das würde ich
auch einfordern weil wenn man sagt man
hat das kann es freiwillig machen dann
macht's niemand muss es durchaus fordern
kann natürlich auch den mehrwert
erklären sagen jeder der etwas gibt
bekommt auch wieder die kritischen
kommentaren konstruktiven kommentar kann
dienen als anstoß nehmen um seine
hausarbeit am ende zu schreiben
da wäre sehr gut sondern leitfaden allen
studierenden vorher zugänglich zu machen
dass die wissen an welche regeln sie
sich zu halten haben
ein punkt ist auch die beiträge sollen
nicht zu lang sein
ich hatte ein teilnehmer der hat dann
unter jedem beitrag zwei seiten
geschrieben und die hat natürlich
niemand gelesen so gut es gemeint war
also ganz klar zu sagen es wird im
zweifel gekürzt da muss man dann selbst
als redakteur fast schon tätig sein sage
ich kürze den beitrag natürlich in
rücksprache mit dem studierenden also
digitale mitarbeit klären ist ganz
wichtig dann sie können
das bietet wordpress eben sie können
benutzerkonten und rollen vergeben als
sie selbst sind an der administrator sie
haben die rechte beiträge freizugeben zu
kontrollieren gegebenfalls noch einmal
zu überarbeiten sie können mitarbeiter
rollen
ihre studierenden vergeben und
neuerdings wird es auch möglich sein mit
der campus kennen ja bisher war das nur
möglich über dann seine private
e-mail-adresse jetzt können sie das über
die lmu selbst machen ich zeige ihnen
wie das geht und ist es ganz offiziell
wird er sich dann mit seiner campus
lockt erkennung einloggt der ist
tatsächlich als student angemeldet als
dann ganz offiziell und ganz legal
ja wir hatte ich schon gesagt referate
als blogbeiträge ist eine möglichkeit
hausarbeiten als wickie artikel ist eine
möglichkeit
aktive teilnahme digitale teilnahme
durch kommentare und diskussionsbeiträge
entweder in foren mit foren bin ich noch
nicht so ganz glücklich
da kommt nicht so eine richtige
diskussion zustande die diskussion muss
immer motive moderiert werden ist auch
ganz wichtig also man muss dabei sein
das läuft nicht von selbst muss immer
wieder input geben
ein mit diskussionsforum bin ich nicht
zufrieden ich zeige nach einer
evaluation das hat sich auch bei mir so
niedergeschlagen dass dass das medium
war was am schlechtesten ankam aber
kommentare ist eine gute möglichkeiten
ganz kurzen kommentar eine andere
möglichkeit ist sie können wie bei
amazon so rating sterne vergeben
also 5 5 sterne maximal ich zeige nach
dem punkt wo die studierenden dann bis
zu fünf sterne vergeben konnten wie der
unmittelbarkeit ein klick auf den stern
darauf gebe ich vier sterne fünf sterne
beitragen und die waren auch sehr fair
ich habe immer die schlechtesten
bewertung bekommen also im schnitt 3,5
und die anderen immer 42
also das ist oder also über vier als die
sind auch recht fair als diddy geben
dann nicht nur null sterne bei den
anderen teil nimmt ja jetzt zum ersten
projekt das ist das blockseminar also
blockseminar ist einfach ein seminar was
eben diese vorteile eines blogs die das
sind aktualität unmittelbarkeit des
zugangs vernetzung archivierung die
versucht hat diese vorteile der block
struktur zu nutzen
ich habe hier so eine grafik das so der
versuch einer darstellung dieser
transformation es war im sommersemester
2016 zum thema philosophische theorien
des lebens
also hier das traditionelle seminar plus
das blatt plus die app gleich
blockseminar dass also der versuch
wir hatten da auch apps im google places
tor und bei apple drin das war der
versuch
und so sieht an die seite aus also ich
kann auch mal klar gerade mal kurz
darauf gehen wir gehen mal kurz drauf
blogs im internet ist die wir gehen da
drauf hier ist es also hier sehen sie
jetzt sieht das blockseminar aus es war
für die theorien des lebens sie sehen
hier den neuesten beitrag organismus als
stoffwechsel und als system die
kontrapunkte von jonas und kann sie
sehen hier unten gibt es diese
abstimmung funktion kann ich bis zu fünf
sterne vergeben der hat jetzt nur eine
abstimmung ergebnis andere haben mehr
bekommen hier zb gehen wir ein bisschen
runter
der hat mal 3,6 von 5 also das war auch
meine hier das ist besser als sie sehen
es gibt da die möglichkeit so
abzustimmen
sie können dann also ist das protokoll
sie sehen hier oben weil sie das lesen
kann die autorin die das geschrieben hat
hier gibt es eine kurze in kurz
inhaltsverzeichnis und können sie hier
ganz kurzen begrüßungstext einen kurzen
auszug lesen gehen sie auch weiter lesen
und dann öffnet das den ganzen text na
dann können sie hier
also springer springen mal zu 2.1 und
dann sind sie da das können sie
verlinken hier sehen sie auch schon so
ein blau hinterlegten begriff
aristoteles klingt ich darauf komme ich
hier zum wiki system mit aristoteles
hier habe ich so ein inhaltsverzeichnis
verbietet und hab da so ein paar
informationen sie sehen auch immer den
autor wer das geschrieben hat sie können
weitere literatur natur verlinken also
dann ins sap-system oder als pdf hier
rechts haben sie zur schlagwörter der
sehen sie welche begriffe besonders
zentral waren der lebens begriff
natürlich
organismus waren wichtiger begriff
urteilskraft
hier sehen sie das bin ich da sehen sie
den autor immer unten das habe ich jetzt
fast sie können hier auf alle beiträge
des autos gehen dann sehen sie hier
so eine statistik sehen sie hier jeder
kann sich praktisch ein benutzerprofil
erstellen
man kann auch im bildraum tun hier sehen
sie dann meine posts die ich gemacht hat
das war ein recht viele in diesem
semester als seminarleiter hier sehen
sie alles als sie sehen dann ganz
personalisierte wann hat er diesen
beitrag gepostet gab es kommentare dazu
da waren jetzt nicht so viele kommentare
das habe ich bei einem anderen seminaren
gemacht also bietet alle möglichkeiten
um immer aktuell hochzuladen und sie
können ihren seminarplan reinstellen
hier
wir haben sind klein kalender noch
rechts wo sind aktuelle dinge angeben
können die neuesten beiträge
also das ist das kam ganz gut an jetzt
gehen wir mal weiter also das ist das
blockseminar das ist der einfachste
sollen die einfachste fall von digitale
aufbereitung
sie haben eine hohe oberfläche eine
wordpress oberfläche sie können sich
dann noch ein titelbild anlegen wenn sie
wollen es aber jetzt nicht notwendig und
die einfachere struktur wir einfach die
ihre teilnehmer posten hier regelmäßig
ihre protokolle oder sonstigen beiträge
drauf nachdem sie die selbst freigegeben
haben das ist so die einfachste
möglichkeit und sie sehen vielleicht
auch noch unten hier
man kann das weiter verlinken also hier
steht jetzt verschlagwortet mit hans
jonas mit kant mit organismus mit
urteilskraft usw
hier sehen sie schon die verlinkung dann
wird das plötzlich ganz vernetzt das
geht ganz schnell
das ist also eine möglichkeit ich hatte
dann ein corporate design auch
entwickelt also das war ein bisschen
spielerei aber ich will es gar nicht
unterschätzen also wir haben dann so
eine so ein maskottchen gehabt so eine
gottesanbeterin haben wir genommen
chimenti hat mir meine hilfskraft dann
grafisch gestaltet war so das symbol für
dieses seminar wir haben auch eine tasse
gehabt ich habe jetzt ich habe eine neue
tasse mittlerweile von 4cast kombinat
drauf es ist ein kollege spielereien
aber sie helfen dass sie tragen dazu bei
dass man so eine art einheits und
corporate identity schafft wo die
teilnehmende das gefühl haben wir sind
jetzt nicht nur an der uni in einem
gemeinsamen raum sondern wir
identifizieren uns auch noch digital
durch gewisse symbole durch gewisse
erkennungsmerkmale ja also lassen sie
ruhig wenn sie kreative hilfskräfte
haben deren fantasie freien lauf es
trägt dazu bei dass man eine digitale
seminar stimmung erzeugt die jetzt nicht
räumlich und zeitlich gestiftet ist
sondern symbolisch zeichenhaft gestiftet
ist ne das sollte man nicht
unterschätzen
ich hab da 20 30 bestellten habe die
verschenkt einfach denke ich kann man
auch mit sachmitteln es sich vielleicht
leisten wie auch immer ich habe es
privat gezahlt aber ich denke sie
könnten das durchaus auch irgendwie
begründen oder so ja das und dann gab es
die app dazu da gehe ich mal kurz ein
bisschen ausführlicher ein bevor ich
nachher zu der konkreten app kommen also
hier haben wir jetzt die dass die
blockseminar app das sehen sie also dass
das menü links
da sehen die neuesten beiträge hier ist
uns leider menü und das ist jetzt ein
konkreter beitrag den ich jetzt geöffnet
habe ich gehe jetzt mal ein bisschen
näher darauf ein wir haben verschiedene
symbole erstellt also das war so ein
zwei wichtige informationen konnte ich
mit push notification versenden wiki
eintrag das war so ein neuer wie die
artikel dann sichtbar war
leitfragen für die nächste sitzung finde
ich ganz wichtig zur nachbereitung dass
die leute wissen hoppla was kommt nach
meiner nächsten sitzungen dran dann
können sie schreiben also bitte lesen
sie diesen text oder ja diesen text
unter folgende leitfragen seite soundso
vision so können text gleich mit
schicken direkt verlinken unter dem
beitrag passwortgeschützt am besten ja
man muss sich natürlich immer ein tv
geworden jetzt halten aufpassen wie
sieht's aus
sie können aber texte direkt verlinken
und wenn sie zum beispiel texte haben
die allgemein frei sind oder als im
internet einfach freie zur verfügung
stehen können sie direkt verlinken
wieder ein klick und man ist sofort da
leitfragen dann technisches formal ist
also wie viele wörter satz nochmal das
protokoll haben
bis wann muss ich die hausarbeit abgeben
das können sie dann verweisen sie
einfach auf dieses diesen reiter
technisches formale schicken den link
hin und dann sind ihre teilnehmer sofort
informiert dass auch verbindlich
begriffs netz ich habe da anfangs mit
die mühe gemacht komplexe begriffe dann
noch grafisch zu veranschaulichen durch
meine hilfskraft hat dann so kleine
grafiken noch verlinkt um geschick kann
man machen
das sind dann links das links symbol
verweis auf andere inhalte im internet
oder auf youtube videos die sie
verlinken können
und hier sehen sie jetzt in der app den
fall dass sich jetzt selbst in der app
dieses wiki system habe also ich klicke
hier auf seele in der zusammenfassung
der zweiten dritten sitzung und komme
dann hier auf den wiki eintrag seele und
kann davon da dann wieder auf andere
begriffe wie aristoteles zum beispiel
hier weil der gegner sehen sie ein auto
das hatte ich jetzt damals verfasst aber
da wäre dann auch der name sichtbar des
jeweiligen studierenden die diesen
beitrag verfasst hat also der vorteil
ist wenn sie ihre inhalte auf eine
wordpress seite stellen können sie von
verschiedenen medien aus auf diese
plattform zugreifen zb von apps in
diesem fall die app bezieht ihre inhalte
aus diesem wordpress seminar genau das
hatte ich schon gezeigt sie können die
bewertung abgeben dass neben der große
vorteil dass man gleich eine rückmeldung
bekommen zu sein beiträgen auf digitale
weise dann zur evolution das wird sie
vielleicht nur kurz interessieren
also hier war die frage wie die das
zusammenspiel von digitalen
traditionellen seminar form gelungen ist
und das war überwiegend positiv es gab
es von party sagten so teils teils aber
der punkt ist hier ist also durchaus im
guten bereich des falls des blogs
seminars wurde dann noch besser im wiki
seminar das sich darauf hatte zum design
das design kann wirklich gut an also die
allermeisten von uns gut also die frage
war war die benutzung des boxens
verständlich leicht möglich also da wird
man immer nur gute bewertung gekommen
weil es einfach direkt unmittelbar
zugänglich ist dann sehen sie hier das
weiß evolution des blogs seminars in
diesem sommersemester 2016 hier sehen
sie seine verlaufs kurve wie die
verschiedenen medien
die ich angeboten hatte bewertet wurden
hier sieht man doch seine kleine delle
damals war dieses wiki nicht schon gut
aber es war jetzt nicht der favorit
dieses wiki system und auch das forum
war jetzt nicht so der renner
das forum aber was ganz klar war wenn es
blöd war gut und auch die begriffs netze
und die audioaufzeichnung die ich auch
eingestellt hatte sie können also das
seminar aufnehmen mit tonbandgerät
stellen das rheinland können sich die
leute es nach hören das kam gut an
nachdem ich dann im wintersemester
daraufhin ein wiki seminar entwickelt
hatte wo das der wiki artikeln eine viel
größere bedeutung bekam wo auch viel
mehr kommentare den artikeln dann
erlassen wurde
da war es dann genau andersrum darin war
dann der wiki artikel hier sehen sie
fast bei 5 also der war der absolute
favorit noch besser als das blog sogar
was eigentlich gar nicht denkbar ist
wickie geht es wie der artikel kamera
ganz ohne blogs hinbekommen aber die
teilnehmern hatten das dann wirklich als
sehr sehr lohnenswert empfunden wenn man
sich eben die mühe macht diese wiki
struktur von der seminar anlage her zu
begründen und auch verbindliche regeln
zu erlassen wie sowas auszusehen hat
also ich kann sagen dass doch noch zwei
semestern sich das gut eingespielt hatte
und denke dass es durchaus
verallgemeinerungsfähig ist dass es
überall so ist hier sehen sie noch kurz
die zugriffszeiten also wie heute
zukunfts punkte wie häufig haben die
teilnehmer dass die blockseminar seite
genutzt so zwei mal zwei bis dreimal pro
woche
die seminare haben sie genauso oft
benutzt ein bisschen häufiger sogar noch
sieht man hier also durchaus ein paar
mal und auch von dem geschlecht herden
ist immer ganz aktuell ich müsste jetzt
eigentlich noch ein drittes nach dem
neuesten urteil aber es war eben davor
also 50 50 dass jetzt war wirklich
positiv also kam gleich gut an
also ich war dann zufrieden und das
wirklich sie mir aber eben das
nachfolgeprojekt da sehen sie jetzt hier
so sieht es aus das ist ein bisschen ein
bisschen schlanker sie sehen wie das ein
eigenes logo das kann ich wirklich
empfehlen lassen sie sich so eine eigene
logo design was diese einheit leistet
auch wieder hier rechts
die begriffswolke und hier dann die
beiträge
ich kann auch noch mal ganz kurz hier
nochmal auf ein wiki seminar gehen hier
sehen sie das mal ein bisschen größer
also hier kann ich runter scrollen
hier habe ich kategorien das gehen wir
mal hier auf irgendwie ein beitrag also
da gab es hier dann einen beitrag von
einem stand über viele perfekt das ist
eine neue philosophie und dann sehen sie
hier unten paar kommentare das ist dann
auch personalisierte also hier
konstruktive vorschlag ich hab da einen
kommentar unten abgegeben dass ich dass
da noch was verbessert werden müsste und
so weiter und die teilnehmer haben dann
die möglichkeit gehabt diese beiträge am
ende aufzunehmen
wie sehen sie auf fußnoten also ist
alles verliebt als war letztendlich so
etwas schlankeres mehr auf den begriff
konzentriertes blockseminaren also da
steht jetzt die wiki struktur ganz
kleinen vorteil hier sehen sie autor
schlagworte sie könnten hier noch
auszeichnen ich habe hier einen punkt
mit aufzeichnungen wo ich die wied die
audioaufzeichnung eingestellt hatte das
war aber nur registrierten nutzern
mögliche gibt es ein login das können
sie auch machen
sie machen login-bereich auch mit dem
plug in kostenlos möglich dann müssen
sich in benutzername eingeben und das
passwort loggen sie sich ein und können
sie alle funktionen nutzen
selbst beiträge verfassen und so weiter
und so fort
genau das ist wirklich seminar also das
ist recht gut gelaufen also
konzentration auf wiki beiträge
verlinkung dieser beiträge und
kommentare kommentierung dieser beiträge
das kam recht gut an auch da hatte ich
eine app will ich nur ganz kurz zeigen
die war noch sinnvoller weil man hier
dann in der app selbst auch die
kommentare sehen konnte hier sehen sie
oben dieses sprechblase heißt dieser
artikel hat 2 kommentare und hier ist
jetzt eine dieser kommentare denen sie
direkt von der app aus sich anschauen
konnte und sie konnten auch selbst von
der app außen kommentar verfassen in dem
sind einfach hier einen kommentar
hinterlassen hatten
also soviel dazu und jetzt das neueste
projekt und das kann ich auch empfehlen
das ist jetzt so ein youtube kanal als
das ist jetzt hier dieses dieses projekt
hier viel los ist sie haben auch so eine
kleine kleine flyer glaube ich hier aber
von ihren sitzen
das ist jetzt der versuch einen eigenen
youtube kanal zu erstellen
mit regelmäßigen themen sendungen das
muss jetzt also nicht nur semester
begleitend sein sind es kann zb ihren
fachbereich betreffen das kann ein
aktuelles forschungsprojekt sein was ich
über mehrere semester aus den tezkan
sonstiger themenschwerpunkt sein
da könnten sie in eigenen youtube kanal
machen das kann ich sehr empfehlen also
youtube-kanal ereignen sich nicht wie es
apps tun oder blogs tun wenn nur ein
semester seminar seien youtube kanäle
eignen sich für längerfristige projekte
regelmäßige themen sendung da können sie
zum beispiel ganz tolle möglichkeit
experteninterview so mache ich das wenn
ich mal wieder eine tagung habe hier in
münchen über philosophie dann habe ich
mir eine referentin referenten wo sie
ins büro von meinem chef baut ein
kleines studio auf mit kamera und
interview mit fünf bis zehn minuten und
die freuen sich drüber erst sind sie ein
bisschen scheu und ich will nicht und so
hat noch nie gemacht aber nach erfinden
die dass alle ganz klasse und ich habe
da schon recht bekannte philosophinnen
philosophen vor die kamera bekommen und
meine studierenden schätzen dass er also
die klickzahlen sind recht hoch dann bei
solchen videos sie können aber auch
selbst die seminar diskussion
weiterführen indem sie zum beispiel
interview mit einem studierenden haben
oder selbst eigenen beitrag bringen die
eine seminar sitzung oder ein thema nach
bereitet das war jetzt bei mir
philosophen philosophen und sie können
eben auch ihre eigenen lehrveranstaltung
aufnehmen mit seiner kamera oder sie
können zum beispiel bei tagungen oder
workshops natürlich müssen sie fragen
klar dass die referenten damit
einverstanden sind sie können auch die
auszeichnung zum beispiel nehmen das
jetzt auf und stellt das jetzt später
auffiel okas sie finden jetzt mein
vortrag nachher also in ein zwei tagen
auf die lowcost können sie das dem
youtube kanal nach
und sie könnte es auch anbinden also das
habe ich auch angebunden an der app und
die könnten sie wenn sie wollen können
sie sich die schon mal runterladen wenn
sie auf diesen app store gehen und von
google oder von apple einfach mal
eingeben philo cast und dann finden sie
da die app zum download können sich
geändert herunterladen nichts versteht
noch einmal eine push notification ob
das klappt jetzt zeige ich ihnen mal
ganz kurz
diese diese das vieh lowcost was ich mir
vorgenommen hatte
und zwar zeige ich das mal so das ist
jetzt hier die youtube seite
so sieht die aus wir haben logo wie das
ganz wichtig habe jetzt 93 abonnenten
wenn ich 7 mehr habe dann bekomme ich
einen eigenen namen und habe ich so ein
kleinen dann darf ich mir so eigenen
also youtube schaltet es frei je mehr
nutzer man hat abonnenten desto mehr
funktionen bekommt man sage ich immer
ganz kurz hier den dass das intro das
sind auferlegt
genau das ist dieses intro und wenn sie
dann mal schauen finden sie hier gewisse
playlist sie können also zb playlists
erstellen von tagungen hier sehen sie
ich habe vor kurzem los am wochenende
tagen über die lebensform gehabt ich
zeichne das mal ganz kurz da finden sie
dann hier auch mein vortrag also dass
das sehen sie meinen vortrag aber auch
von anderen referenten auf der tagung
mit ihrem einverständnis habe ich das
gefühl ein neues format kilo kaffee view
da geht es um studenten stimme
der typische philosophiestudium grund
als sie können eben ihre teilnehmer sie
können sie können auch zu den wirklich
studienanfängern kontakt herstellen es
gibt also verschiedene zielgruppen sage
ich jetzt mal so es gibt also
zielgruppen das sind also dass
studienanfänger es gibt zielgruppen zum
beispiel jetzt philo kaarst das war
interview mit einem bekannten philosoph
volker gerhardt als volker gerhardt und
bekannter nietzsche forscher den habe
ich einfach so bei einer tagung so kurz
entführt und der hat dann ja gesagt und
das ist kommt recht gut anders hat es
340 aufrufe also sie können auch das
bewerten sie sehen es gibt dann auch
bewertungen wie viel
häufig sind gefallen hat hier viel okas
themen sendung
genau also da haben wir dann über alle
möglichen themen sendung hier wird das
böse was ist eine person was animalis
muss lotter erasmus als sie können da
ganz eigene playlists erstellen
je nach thema könnte es dann sofort
verlinken sie können die videos
einbinden müsse natürlich immer die
genehmigung einholen die jeweiligen
referenten fragen sind sie damit
einverstanden aber nach einiger zeit
legt sich die scheu und also ich habe
noch keinen referierenden kennengelernt
er gesagt hat bitte nehmen sie es wieder
runter also es kommt in der regel gut an
also auch bei den nutzern also das ist
so der vorteil dass man eben ganz
spezifische sendung erstellen kann
und auch hier gibt es die logistep
vielleicht hat sich der ein oder andere
von ihnen das schon heruntergeladen
weil dann kann jetzt mal ein kleines
experiment probieren
eslohe ich mich nämlich ein bei philo
kasten und verschicke mal diese push
notification
es muss viel oka sein und das ist hier
viel okas sehen sie ich hab da auch eine
homepage und hier sehen sie hier habe
ich die ganzen sachen reingehe verlinkt
direkt also da habe ich den youtube link
einfach rein verlinkt jetzt glaub ich
mich doch ganz kurz ein und dann
versuchen das nur kurz ob das geht
und jetzt sehen sie schon gleich das
wollte ich mich auch noch zeigen wenn
sie ein wordpress projekt haben ich
zeige ihnen am ende noch wie sie das
bekommen haben sie ja ein so genanntes
dashboard das ist die schaltzentrale mit
dem sie ganz einfach wie gesagt ein
klick neubeiträge erstellen können sie
gehen einfach hier auf neue post und
geben dann einen titel ein titel
irgendwie test und dann sind sie sofort
hier im nächsten fenster sofort hier in
dem text niveau sie beliebige inhalte
hineinkopieren können also ihr könnt
dann wirklich inhalt da können dann ihre
studierenden oder sie selbst dieses feld
unter dem titel die direkten inhalte
hinein kopieren und wenn sie dann hier
auf veröffentlichen klicken hier rechts
ist es sofort mit einem klick im netz
also wenn sie als administrator hier
draufklicken ist es für jeden sichtbar
ihre studierenden könnte es nicht weil
es wird ihnen erst vorgelegt auch gut so
aber sie haben dann hier die
verantwortung ganz offiziell
dann ist das drin jetzt gehe ich mal
hier kurz darauf auf mobil out das heißt
nämlich dieses angebot
sie sehen hier ich weiß nicht ob man
sehen kann ich habe hier ein überblick
wie viele leute sich diese app
heruntergeladen haben 1997 haben sich
das runtergeladen und jetzt jetzt
verstehe ich einfach mal eine nachricht
verstehe ich mal einfach test oder
hattest
und jetzt schauen wir ob das klappt ach
jetzt machen wir das hier lebensform
ich verschicke keine push notification
die direkt auf ein neues video auf viele
fast verwaist
jetzt hoffe mal dass es klappt es jetzt
wichtig sind charakter
ja ich hab was gehört also bei einem
jahr hat es geklingelt so jetzt können
sie sehen sie mal drauf schauen sehen
sie jetzt haben sie da so ein link und
jetzt können sie da drauf gehen wenn sie
darauf gehen kommen sie auf diesen
beitrag direkt wo sie dieses video dann
auf der app schauen können oder also
müsste es sein das wird dann verlinkt
also genau das ist eine möglichkeit
geben direkt mit einem klick sofort ihre
studierenden zu erreichen
dazu eignet sich das gut ja so viel
genau bisher genau das ist eben das ist
der punkt bei dieser bei dieser app das
funktioniert nicht bei allen bei den
vorherigen hat es geklappt also das ist
immer so noch nicht ganz ausgereift aber
bei denen ja sie könnte es also von der
app aus können sie es dann so steuern
dass sie es auch unterdrücken also dass
deswegen gesagt jetzt auch experiment
dieses diese app funktioniert nicht ganz
hundertprozentig mit dem push
notifications aber bei ein paar hat
funktioniert dass es immerhin erfreulich
und sie können dann hier sehen also es
hat dann hier den ladebildschirm hier
hat es dann verschiedene optionen es
gibt zum beispiel auch gewisses will ihn
noch kurz zeigen also da kommen nämlich
auf nächsten punkt ich habe verschiedene
symbole hier vergeben zum beispiel
dieses kuh das ist für quiz das gilt für
quiz und ich hatte ihn ja schon anfang
gesagt wie es die quizze erstellen
können die quiz können sie erstellen mit
adobe captivate das ist ein programm das
sie sich hier lizenzieren können von
adobe die auch ihren acrobat reader
machen sind recht und fortgeschrittene
software-schmiede die auch eine eigene
universität betreibt
den usa weil die programme so komplex
sind sie können also verschiedene quiz
formen machen sie können multiple choice
sie können zuordnung skizze machen wo
man eine begriff einem anderen begriff
zuordnen muss und hotspot wo sie auf das
richtige bild klicken müssen oder auf
mehr richtige bilder das ist vielleicht
für naturwissenschaften interessanter
oder lückentext den man ausfüllen muss
es gibt eine automatische auswertung es
ist online und offline möglich hatte ich
schon gesagt es gibt verschiedene export
formate pdf html oder flash sie können
auch eine eigene stimme eingabe machen
das heißt sie können die fragen selbst
vorlesen also sprechen lassen
sie können screencasts machen screencast
heißt sie können praktisch eine aufnahme
ihres monitors machen wenn sie da
irgendwie was rein schreiben oder mit
der maus irgendwo hin bewegen können sie
das was sie an ihrem monitor machen
aufnehmen zu einem video und danach noch
mal abspielen lassen
der preis 200 euro ist nicht gerade
billig es gibt eine limo lizenz können
sie bestellen hier die lmu das
leibniz-rechenzentrum 200 euro müssen
sich überlegen ist eine schöne stange
geld ich bin aber der meinung es lohnt
sich zeigen jetzt noch ganz kurz was man
damit machen kann und zwar ist das jetzt
hier dieses sein programm weil ich
gerade geöffnet habe und hier habe ich
jetzt verschiedene projekte geöffnet ich
habe jetzt mal hier ein luther kings
geöffnet das lädt jetzt heim superquiz
die grafik hat mir meine hilfskraft
gemacht hier so ein bisschen mit text
hier sehen sie jetzt verschiebt das ist
wie powerpoint kündigen sie sehen links
verschiedene folien das sind frage
folien und die können sie anklicken und
dann können sie hier ganz einfach fragen
vergeben das jetzt ganz einfach wann
wurde luther geboren so weiß sie können
aber auch ein lückentext machen luther
veröffentlichte seine wie viele thesen
im jahr anzupassen
das ist eine zuordnung also albrecht war
was albrecht war ein erzbischof damals
leo der zehnte war ein papst luther so
hieß der mutter ja bevor sich luther
genannt hat war ein augustiner mensch
das sind die zuordnung sachen dann gibt
es noch den hot spots auch noch kurz das
hier ist der hotspot hier müssen sie
dann auf das richtige bild klicken
rasmus von rotterdam wo ist ja
können sie also alles definieren und am
ende gibt es eine automatische
auswertung sie können definieren mit wie
viel punkten der test bestanden ist sie
können also für jede frage punkte
vergeben sie können aber auch straff
punkte vergeben wenn sie vor
das können sie alles machen jetzt machen
wir projekt abspielen
sehen sie mal wie das projekt fertig
aussieht wenn ich jetzt abspielen
genau jetzt können sie hier wurde
geboren natürlich 1483 senden und dann
sehen sie hier richtig sehen dann sofort
die ausgabe und dann kommt eben die
nächste frage tragen für vollständig sie
diesen text wird er veröffentlichte
seine 95 thesen im jahr 1517 können sie
wieder eingeben und dann kriegen sie
eben die auswahl die angaben hat also so
könnte das machen hier können sie sagen
hier albrecht war ein erzbischof gehe
ich auf pelé oder zehnte war ein papst
gehe ich auf c lukas ist er war der
augustiner münch dann kriege ich hier
wieder die unmittelbare auswertung ja
genau es gibt dann auch die auf die
angabe dass sie dann zehn teilweise
richtig diese nur teilweise richtig
genau genau also gesagt öffnen ich habe
noch ein projekt hier was kann ich ihnen
noch zeigen ich habe hier so viel los
ist ich habe auch noch zu toren
ausbildung gemacht
das hat dann auch wieder corporate
design also wirklich luther hat dann so
sein ding das ist jetzt eine andere
farbe das jetzt viel lokal ist ein filou
tutor spiele ich ihnen auch mal kurz ab
das war zu meiner tutoren ich hab
tutoren ausgebildet da habe ich auch ein
quiz erstellt das die ihre bisherigen
erlangten kenntnisse unter beweis
stellen konnten
also habe ich eine extra eine
schauspielschülerin engagiert die eine
stimmbildung genossen hat die mir das
dann eingesprochen hat also nach welchem
schema sollte ein konstruktives feedback
erfolgen natürlich beschreibung
interpretation und bewertung
solche dinge kann man hier dann senden
und uns so nah sie können verschiedene
inhalte einfach hier genau also das kann
man jetzt beliebig ergänzen
sie können das selbst ein sprechen hier
gibt es dann so ein lautsprecher symbol
da gehen sie einfach auf medien und dann
hier auf audio- und könnte es dann
einbinden sie können aber auch hier auf
aufzeichnen gehen auf dieses rote mikro
und könnte jetzt fast ein sprechen
sie können selbst die fragen auch
vorlesen lassen das ist jetzt vielleicht
nicht unbedingt notwendig sie könnten
die frage selbst ein sprechen und dann
abspielen lassen
dann hat es noch einen gleichen engeren
bezug zu ihnen als dozenten
also das ist captivate das captivate
wenn sie mal diese viel okaz tab sich
noch mal ein bisschen durchschauen da
habe ich dann auch diese gewisses darin
verlinkt sie können also dieses quiz
auch von der viel okaz tab direkt auf
dem smartphone machen sie können selbst
dann malte wirtz gewisses lösen weil
eben der vorteil ist dass es auf html5
basis ist und das ist ziemlich
universell einzusetzen das können sie
mit jedem endgerät im grunde kaum
benutzten ich meine 200 euro ist doch
nicht stange geld müsste schauen aber
der vorteil ist sie können es auf
mehreren pcs installieren wenn es also
wenn es sie ihre pc sehen können es auch
zwei installieren das glaube ich erlaubt
also zu hause und an der uni müssen sie
nicht immer an einem pc das machen
also ich habs jetzt nicht bereut ich
finde ich konnte viele interessante
projekte mitmachen ich habe das ganze
programm noch gar nicht ausgeschöpft ich
habe vielleicht nur zehn prozent genutzt
ich bin auch noch nicht richtig drin ich
hatte mir noch ein dickes handbuch
gekauft was es dazu gibt kann man
unendlich viel mitmachen noch ja jetzt
möchte ich noch ganz kurz zum schluss
erklären was wordpress eigentlich ist
ich habe das jetzt immer so
vorausgesetzt dass sie das wissen also
wordpress ist eine kostenlose plattform
ein kostenloses blog system mit dem sie
eben viele textformen unmittelbar
schnell und auch kompetent und grafisch
schön formatiert ins internet bekommen
also ich gebe in der kurzen überblick
das ist kostenlos es ist ein content
management system als sie können inhalte
sehr zentral sehr komfortabel verwalten
es ist intuitiv es hat ständige updates
es ist ideal für blogs und foren und
begleitend zu seminaren das design ist
individuell anpassbar sie können sonst
bestimmte teams also themen sondern
thematische grafiken oder designs ist
vielleicht der beste begriff können sie
sich kostenlos laden also wenn sie sagen
dieses design gefällt mir nicht ich
möchte das menü an der recht
seit ich mit seiner linken seite oben
haben suchen sie sich das kostenlos
meistens kostenlos passende design
heraus und laden es einfach runter und
mit einem klick sieht das ganze aus so
wie sie wollen also nicht viel anpassen
und mit einem klick haben sie das ganze
es ist erweiterbar durch plug-ins auch
adobe captivate quiz können sie direkt
einbinden also schnittstellen mäßig sehr
gut ausgestattet und es ist eben auch
exportierbar als app sie können
wordpress inhalte nutzen als
ausgangsbasis auf die sie über
verschiedene medien verschiedene formate
darauf zugreifen weil es einfach so
viele schnittstellen handeln das
wordpress hatten extreme verbreitung ja
also extrem häufig heruntergeladen
worden
zwischen 50 und 60 prozent aller
websites basierend auf wordpress die ein
content management system haben also
extrem große verbreitung als sie setzen
damit auf ein programm auf eine software
die längerfristig noch aktuell sein wird
ist immer das problem wenn man jetzt
nicht auf ein system festlegt wird es in
fünf jahren noch existieren wenn es
nicht mehr existiert wird das
dateiformat nicht mehr unterstützt dann
ist alles offline also da kann ich ihn
für mich mit ziemlich großer
wahrscheinlichkeit sagen dass es in fünf
bis zehn jahren noch existieren wird das
sind 26 prozent des gesamten internets
ist wordpress passiert das schon enormen
dann gibt die schaltzentrale hatte ich
ihnen schon gezeigt haben das dashboard
die schaltzentrale sie können hier ihre
beiträge verwalten sie können einzelne
benutzer neu aufnehmen sie können ja
verlinken sie können einen plug ins
installieren
also das ist auch total intuitiv
eingängig dass folgt auch diesem prinzip
ein klick regel ein klick und es ist ein
inhalts sichtbar
dabei spiele habe ich ihnen schon eine
genannt blockseminar wiki seminare.de
seminare habe ich noch viele tutor
luther 2017 bayern
wir reduzieren den netzwerk- und so
weiter und so fort sie können wirklich
in zehn minuten können sie eine neue
homepage machen zehn minuten nichts
programmieren alles intuitiv
zugänglichen
plugins muss ich auch noch erwähnen so
wie ich jetzt gemacht habe ich alleine
gehostet das müssen sie nämlich nicht
machen das ist der große vorteil da
komme ich am schluss darauf zu sprechen
ich hatte es eben alleine gemacht
eigenständig da musste ich natürlich
auch dafür sorgen dass die sicherheit
gewährleistet war also ich habe ein
spamschutz installiert weil sonst wäre
nach einem tag das ganze forum überfüllt
gewesen dass beim schutz plugin firewall
es gibt gab durchaus auch angriffe
benutzerverwaltung und registrierung
können sie auch über plugins regeln
sie können sich auch eine statistik
plugin installieren dann ziehen sie
genau wie viele zugriffe hat jetzt
dieser beitrag an diesem tag wie viele
klicks hatte ich pro woche sie können
daraus ableiten die viele nutzer sie
erreichen das ist ziemlich hilfreich
sie können ein medienplayer installieren
und eigene aufnahmen zum beispiel nur
tondokumente habe ich manchmal setzt
sendung sitzung nur per audio
aufzeichnung archiviert sie können diese
tondokumente direkt rein stellen
abspielen über so ein medienplayer von
dieser seite habe ich schon gesagt es
gibt es schnittstellen genau ich hatte
das damals alleine gemacht wie gesagt
und hatte es dann selbst hosten lassen
über 1&1 strato das waren 5 euro pro
monat inklusive domain das war für mich
ganz gut weil ich hatte eben ein seminar
titel wirklich seminar gab man dass ein
ins internet und war mit einem klick
drauf wie gesagt 15 minuten hat es
gedauert
ich habe es also auf eigene kosten
gemacht das ist aber gar nicht mehr
notwendig weil wie ich ihn jetzt gleich
noch sagen wird dass die lmu münchen für
sie machen kann sie brauchen das nicht
selbst zu bezahlen falls sie sich
interessieren doch dazwischen für eine
app falls sie eine app erstellen wollen
das auch möglich es gibt allerdings nur
wenige anbieter
ich empfehle mobil out das ist auch der
hersteller meiner app die sie jetzt hier
gesehen haben diese flog a step das ist
mobil out dies sind die gebühren sind
noch recht hoch das sind mindestens 30
euro pro monat und das muss man sich
wirklich überlegen ob es das wert ist
das ist jetzt ein native app dass also
die best aussehens die app die es gibt
diese nativ die ist also extra programm
sie kriegen sicherlich kostenlos oder
sehr kostengünstig so genannte html5
apps die dann eher so eine art
verknüpfung darstellen wo einfach sie
dann also eine ab eine verknüpfung auf
ihrem smartphone haben sie klicken auf
die verknüpfung und es öffnet dann diese
seite in diesem format also wordpress
hat den riesenvorteil dass es responsive
ist responsive heißt es das format passt
sich an das jeweilige ausgabegerät an
also das ist optimiert sozusagen für
alle möglichen endgeräte webseiten genau
sie bekommen dann eben push
notifications wenn sie es über mobi laut
machen haben sie eben im app store in
google store eine eigene eigenen als
angebot und der vorteile ist beim obi
laut dass wenn sie den vertrag kündigen
also sie brauchen praktisch nur einen
monat lang den vertrag laufen zu lassen
wird die app danach immer noch nutzbar
sein das ist toll
sie brauchen dann nicht monat für monat
zahlen sie können zwar keine push
notifications mail verschicken aber die
app ist nach wie vor dem store
erhältlich und sie können auch nach wie
vor neue inhalte drauf stellen also mit
30 euro haben sie es eigentlich dann
fast so ein trick also dann also fazit
des wordpress wordpress ist der standard
apps sind noch zu teuer vielleicht
zumindest die nativen apps sei denn sie
machen es mit diesem trick sie kaufen
einmal für einen monat und lassen dann
den vertrag dann haben sie es immer
drauf auf dem store sie können videos
einbinden das ist sehr sehr wichtig in
wordpress ist intuitiver als model noch
beachten sie die sicherheit und
datenschutz wenn sie selbst hosten als
spam und hacker angriffe weil sie müssen
bedenken sie haben ja auch viele daten
von ihren teilnehmern darauf die sich
mit ihren e-mails adressen eingeloggt
haben also muss ein bisschen aufpassen
es ist auch ideal für die langfristige
dokumentation und es ist prinzipiell
offen für alle das problem momentan ist
eben noch dass es bislang noch nicht
offiziell gehostet wurde von der lmu und
dass es sicherheitsprobleme gab
das ist jetzt aber und das führt mich
zum letzten punkt durchaus in angriff
genommen worden also es gibt jetzt
digitale angebot der lmu ich komme aus
den geisteswissenschaften für mich
zentral ist da
dieses lmu center for digital humanities
also da können sie mal drauf die tgh ist
diese seite auch lehrern die störche
manager
die haben schon sowas gemacht und das
will ich ihnen auch mal kurz zeigen dass
die gruppe geisteswissenschaften ich
denke es gibt es auch in den anderen
wissenschaften wenn sie mal dann schauen
bei naturwissenschaften ob sowas gibt
also die haben hier einige angebote und
das ist jetzt das was die haben sie
sehen gleich dass es auch wordpress
passiert dass die t gruppe
geisteswissenschaften und die haben
jetzt hier schon einige veranstaltungen
auf ihrer seite abgebildet zum beispiel
jetzt hier beschreibung abbildung und
visualisierung von sprache und text es
war eine übung aus dem ist aus diesem
semester eine übung und da sehen sie
jetzt auch hier ähnlich wie sie es bei
mir gesehen hatten hier letzte beiträge
der veranstaltung rechts gibt es eine
übersicht menü dann gibt es hier so
inhalt und hier können sind kommentar
verfassen
also da ist gerade was dabei in bewegung
das ist der vorteil von der gruppe ist
das eben nicht jeder sein eigenes
süppchen kocht sind dass alle seminare
dann zentral zugänglich sind über diese
seite hier das sieht wieder ein bisschen
anders aus hier sehen sie kann man
grafiken reinstellen seminarplan kann
man rein stellen gliederung wieder
kommentieren
ja also das ist die siebte diese idee
gruppe geisteswissenschaften bietet es
an als wenn sie jetzt aus dem bereich
der geisteswissenschaften kommen
schreiben sie einfach an nicht nur noch
ein punkt ist der vorteil ist dass sie
da ein offizielles login mit campus
kennung bekommen also das ist dann ganz
offiziell da muss nicht irgendwann
jemand seine normale e mail adresse
angeben irgendwie gmail oder gmx zahlen
da kommt man mit seiner campus kennen
dann in dieses wordpress system rein
man bekommt offizielle benutzerprofile
und kann das ganze eben dann auch
offiziell vernetzen mit anderen
lehrveranstaltungen die an der lmu
angeboten werden
und sie können eben auch sehr offiziell
zitieren und sie können versionieren als
sie können bestimmte versionen eines
beitrags speichern das machen die
automatisch dass wenn sie sagen weil ich
will diesen beitrag von vor einem monat
zitieren dann geben die ihnen den
direkten link und das ist
wissenschaftlich einwandfrei das würde
ich vorschlagen als ich würde das bevor
sie ist jetzt ein eigenes blog sich
erstellen was sie selbst zahlen müssen
wo sie im sicherheitsbedenken haben
müssen lassen sie sich das ruhig
erstellen von so einem anbieter der eu
sei es jetzt den naturwissenschaften
oder in den geisteswissenschaften hier
für die geisteswissenschaften ist er
christian riepen zuständig denke den
können sie gerne auch anschreiben wenn
sie aus einem anderen bereich kommt der
hilft ihnen
ich habe mit ihm gesprochen letzte woche
war sehr interessiert daran hindert auch
angebote machen zu können
das wäre so letztendlich die offizielle
lösung dessen was ich in den letzten
semestern ihr privat für mich gemacht
hatte ja das wäre es auch schon vielen
dank für die aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]